I need you to understand something you
have so much time I'm in entrepreneur
land and I meet with all these kids and
they're taking advantage of the new
world right but they're young and
they're wrong some of them are great and
they'll be all-time great but what blows
me away is how many of you have decided
that you're finished that you're on the
back end of your life that you can't
accomplish it that this wasn't built for
you I didn't grow up with this [__]
either but I figured it out you figured
out how to drive you figured out how to
be a parent you figured it all out and
with the health Trends and the way the
world is now you've got a long life in
front of you so instead of sitting in
that job for the next 10 years go do
your thing you've got plenty and plenty
of time